as a warm-up just to see how to use
steady-state probabilities let us look
at our familiar example this is a two
state Markov chain and we did write down
the complete balance equations for this
chain and found the steady-state
probabilities before notice that we can
find these by using the trick which we
introduced for birth and death processes
you cut the chain along this line and
argue that the frequency of transition
of this type has to be the same as the
frequency of transition of this type so
if you have PI 1 here and PI 2 here what
it means is PI 1 times 0.5 which
represent the frequency of these kind of
transitions to be close to PI 2 times
0.2 just this kind of transition plus PI
1 plus PI 2 the normalization equation
and by solving the system of equation
you obtain the same thing as what we
obtained before which is the steady
state probabilities of state 1 and of
state 2 let us now try to calculate some
related quantities suppose that you
start at state 1 and you want to
calculate this particular probability so
you start at state 1 and you want to
know what is the probability that next
time you will be in state 1 and 100 time
steps that later you are still in state
1 now the conditional properties of two
things happening is the conditional
value of the first one happening X 1
equals 1 given X 0 goes 1 and even that
the first one happens the priority that
the second one happened 1 given X 1
equals 1
so what is this this first one is the
transition priority from state 1 to
state 1 p1 1
how about the second probability because
of the Markov property that information
is irrelevant and so that probability is
r1 1 in 99 steps now 99 is possibly a
big number and so we approximate this
quantity and we are going to use the
steady state priority of state 1 for
doing that and that gives us an
approximation P 1 1 times pi of 1 which
then is 0.5 times 2 over 7 now how about
this expression given that you start in
state 1 what is the priority that at
time step 100 you are in 1 and time step
1 and 1 you're in two by doing the same
technique is the conditional priority of
the first thing happening and then given
that thing happening the priority that
the second one happened when it was 2
given X 100 equals 1 and x equals 1 and
again here what we have is r1 1 of 100
and x again the Markov property tells us
that we can forget about this one and
this is the priority transition from 1
to 2 I want to and again here if N
equals 100 is large enough we can
approximate that by PI 1 times
you want to and this is then 2 over 7
times 0.5 again family let's calculate
this third expression where again we
start at state 1 and now we are asking
what is the priority that after times
that 100 you are in 1 and 1 on steps
later you are again in 1 we use the same
trick as before this priority that the
first thing happened and given that the
priority of the second one happened
again this is our 1 1 of 100 and this
one for the same reason as before we can
forget this term from 100 to 200 you
have 100 time steps are one one of 100
and one other these begin apps so we can
approximate both by the same values and
we get PI 1 square just over 7 square
now in this calculation we assume that N
equals 99 or N equals 100 were big
enough big enough so that the limit has
taken effect but how do we know that our
proximation is good in other words is N
equals 99 or 100 large enough
well this has something to do with a
mixing time scale of our Markov chain
and by mixing time scale I mean how long
does it take for the initial states to
be forgotten so how can you see that
here while you can first try it
simulation so using any of your favorite
software simulate if you calculate and
you look at as a function of N and you
draw our 1 1 of n at N equals 0 this is
1 and equals 1 then you have 5 at 1 this
is going to be P 1 1 and P 1 1 was 0.5
so already it's here so initially it was
your here and 2 over 7 so this is 0.5 2
over 7 is year and what we know is that
when n goes to infinity these things
goes to 2 over 7 and if you simulate you
will see that it goes very fast so here
I'm just joining points and you will see
that at N equals 5 already you are very
very close to 2 over 7 so you have a
really an exponential decrease here
in fact if you look at the simulation
result and you look at N equals five
already here you have to correct decimal
already and for N equals 10 it's correct
up to five decimals or if you do not
want to have simulation but simply think
in terms of order of magnitude so here
it would be another approach would be
like order of magnitude type of
arguments and in order to do that
starting here on average how many trials
how many time steps would it take in
order for you to observe such a
transition here well you use the
geometric random variable and this is
the amount of time on average until you
have success and it is one over the
probability here so it takes an average
two time steps to go from here to here
and to go from here to here it takes on
average one over zero point two which is
about five times depth so as an order of
magnitude given you started here in
state one after on average about ten
iterations there will be some randomness
there is a likely on average that you
will go there and come here and and if
you do n equals 100 which is 10 times
that in terms of order of magnitude it
looks at n is large enough so that would
be a back to the envelope calculation
now this kind of calculation is useful
in general not just here so for example
let's do it again assume that instead of
0.5 here the probability that you had
was 0.99 and maybe here instead of 0.8
it was 0.998 now in order to observe
socialisation it will take on average
since this number here would become
0.001 it would take on average about
1,000 time steps in order to observe one
such transition so if you look at time
steps of that order it will not be
enough
if your chain wear of this type after n
equals 100 the likelihood would be yet
you will still be here so the initial
state of the initial condition would
matter still so you would take about
1,000 to get there and then here it
would have 0.02 that means that on
average from here you would take about
five hundred iterations before you
observe that for the first time so the
same order of magnitude so in order to
get enough randomness here you know a
good rule would be to multiply this
1,000 by 10 so maybe with N equals
10,000 you would feel confident enough
in that specific case in order to use
this kind of approximation that we have
used here and finally for those
interested you can study that by a
theory and here there is an entire field
that for to study how fast the Markov
chain converges to steady state and the
so called mixing time it turns out that
for these Markov chain you can say that
the convergence so the rate of
convergence is of the order C at the
power n where C is a number that is
between U and 1 and the closer C is to 1
the slower the convergence is and closer
C's to 0
the faster the convergence is and for
example here for our initial a case the
C was zero point three so that was the
first case for the second chain with
this kind of probability 0.99 and the
0.998 the C would be 0.997